I do feel less about Robin from watching
this but I feel like that's not very
fair from me because I don't really like
her as a person Sister Wives star
Gwendolyn Brown has some feelings about
her father Cody's only remaining wife
Robin
the only thing about the second the 21
year old daughter of Cody and Christine
posted a candid reaction video on
YouTube watching an episode from this
season of the family's TLC series and
what I'm kind of doing is watching the
episodes and recounting how I felt in
that time and kind of my experience as
somebody who's not really part of an
flds Community anymore especially as
somebody who's on the entire other
spectrum of that being queer and
autistic and also not being married to a
man with multiple otherwise yeah and
Gwen didn't hold back of course this
past season focused on her mom's
decision to leave her dad so for us
plural merge doesn't work
for us marriage to something the timing
for me to leave was just it opened up
and everything became just things fell
into place once I decided to just I kind
of looked at where my life was and
before I decided to leave and I'm like
do I really want to do this for another
10 years and Gwen she totally supports
her mom I was like you're leaving good
for you she told me that she was moving
and also divorcing my father at like the
same time so I was like all hyped for
her
because like obviously I love her and
obviously I visit her all the time but
like
she's got she was going home and I was
happy for her and I didn't really love
the relationship that they had and she's
doing really great now and once
Gwendolyn started answering fan
questions that's when things got
interesting so has seeing the way people
behave made us feel different about
Robin or Cody
um I do feel less about Robin from
watching this but I feel like that's not
very fair from me because I don't really
like her as a person so it's probably
not a completely valid response but like
a watching her makes me like her less
for sure yep and when someone asked if
Robin really made an effort to reach out
to her former Sister Wives kids Gwen
revealed this so Robin's never reached
out to me like she claims um I reached
out to her on her birthday I like sent
her happy birthday
um but she never did the same to me so
from from my perspective that's not you
know the truth is what she claims but
hey she did have something nice to say
about her stepmother at a recent family
event she did go specific quickly after
my girlfriend and like introduce herself
and Beatrice does say that she was kind
and sweet and so I appreciate her at
least making some sort of an attempt to
reach out as far as Gwen's relationship
with her dad goes she says he's still a
work in progress he's not actively
reaching out to us I've had to reach out
to him and ask when he's available but
he has been working on it and I think
that he is getting better and with time
he will get better
thank you